انظر حولك وخذ نفسًا، ماذا تلاحظ
[موسيقى]
أنه من الصعب تخيل ذلك، ولكن حتى الهواء
الذي يبدو نظيفًا يمكن أن
يظل تلوثًا ضارًا للهواء، حيث يحدث
أي شيء كيميائي أو فيزيائي أو بيولوجي
يغير الغلاف الجوي، وهو الآن
السبب الرئيسي لتلوث الهواء منذ فترة طويلة  كان
الوقود الأحفوري ولكن حرائق الغابات مثل تلك
التي رأيناها كثيرًا مؤخرًا
تؤثر بشكل متزايد على جودة الهواء لدينا
في الواقع كما هي الأمور الآن
وفقًا لمنظمة الصحة العالمية،
فنحن جميعًا تقريبًا نتنفس
هواءًا ملوثًا وهو ما قد
تلاحظه مرة أخرى  حتى لو كان الهواء يبدو جيدًا،
فهناك أعراض مثل تهيج العين والأنف أو الحلق والأزيز والسعال والصداع والتعب والدوخة
ونوع واحد من
تلوث الهواء يسمى التلوث الجزيئي أو
PM2.5 يمكن أن يكون خطيرًا بشكل خاص
وذلك بسبب مدى صغر حجم الجزيئات التي
يمكن لهذه الجزيئات أن تسببها.  يبلغ عرض
شعرة الإنسان مما يعني أنها تستطيع
تجاوز دفاعات الجسم المعتادة،
لذلك عندما
تتنفس بهذه الطريقة بدلاً من الزفير عند الزفير،
يمكن أن تعلق الجسيمات
هنا في رئتيك أو حتى تمر عبر
مجرى الدم مما يعني أنها
يمكن أن  ينتهي الأمر بالتأثير على كل عضو في
جسمك ويمكن أن يسبب التهابًا
في جميع أنحاء جسمك أيضًا، ما
وصفته للتو هو العلاقة
بين تلوث الجسيمات والسرطان
وأمراض القلب، وحتى
الاكتئاب والقلق على مستوى العالم، وقد تم
الآن ربط هذا النوع من التلوث بـ
الآن، واحد من كل خمسة وفيات أعلم أنك تسمع
هذا والكثير من هذا قد يقلقك
ولكن هناك أيضًا طرق يمكنك من خلالها
حماية نفسك أولاً، تمامًا كما
يمكنك التحقق من الطقس قبل
مغادرة المنزل، يجب عليك أيضًا التحقق من
جودة الهواء لديك  في الواقع، تمتلك العديد من البلدان
الآن أدوات لمراقبة
مؤشر جودة الهواء، وهو ما يُعرف باسم aqi،
ولدى الأمم المتحدة أيضًا
حاسبة للتعرض لتلوث الهواء الحي، لذلك عندما تكون
جودة الهواء سيئة، فأنت تعلم أنه
يجب عليك البدء في البقاء في الداخل إذا استطعت
إذا كنت تستطيع ذلك.  يجب عليك الخروج من المنزل، حاول القيام
بأنشطة لا تتنفس فيها
بصعوبة، اذهب للمشي بدلاً من الركض، كن
حذرًا للغاية عندما يكون الجو حارًا بالخارج لأن
درجات الحرارة المرتفعة يمكن أن تزيد من
تلوث الجسيمات، تجنب المناطق التي بها الكثير
من حركة المرور بشكل واضح وربما تكون هناك أوقات
عند ارتداء قناع n95 عالي الجودة
مثل هذا يمكن أن يكون
مفيدًا حقًا، فلا تنس أن الماء هو
صديقك لأسباب واضحة وأيضًا
لأن البقاء رطبًا يسمح
لرئتيك بإنتاج
تزييت طبيعي يمكن أن يساعدك على إخراج
ملوثات الهواء في الداخل والحفاظ على
نوافذك مغلقة.  إذا كان ذلك ممكنًا، استخدم
هواءًا جسيميًا عالي الكفاءة يُعرف باسم
مرشح HEPA وأولئك
الأكثر عرضة للخطر يجب أن يكونوا أكثر
حذرًا، وهذا يشمل الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
أمراض القلب أو الرئة مثل الربو والأطفال
وكبار السن، سيكونون هم
الأشخاص  الأكثر عرضة لتلوث الهواء
ولكن الصورة الكبيرة بالنسبة لنا جميعًا هي
الاهتمام بالهواء من حولك